but you just celebrated your daughter's
graduation that's amazing so are you and
katherine
ready to be empty nesters um
yeah i i think so i mean
we had a lovely experience it was a
virtual graduation
he couldn't actually be in the same room
that she was in
um because of covert protections and all
of that
and i was so wonderful i'm so proud of
her but i got to tell you kelly
it's a little rough and you're going out
the doors and the other parents
are saying oh congratulations say thank
you congratulations to you
i said you must be so proud of your
granddaughter
i said well
i don't know man i i i don't know yeah
okay
i'm not gonna take it personal you know
i thought they're just trying to be nice
but uh yeah we had you know we we we
were we were getting ready for it
uh and we prepared but then when when
the covet happened and we had everybody
back home
uh this past year yeah but there is that
moment you know
uh when you when they're gone and
they're out of the house and they're
gone
and you look at each other and in the
back of your mind thinking
what are we going to talk about what
are we doing you get to date again you
get to dating people
well yeah you can do all that but you
really you as a marriage you
so much of your time evolves where i'm
talking about your kids
you know what they're doing how are they
doing and this and that's an easy
conversation
so uh i think we're gonna do real well
we're we we got our our our suitcases
packed
uh the kobe is getting down we're
looking to do a lot of traveling in the
next couple of years moving around
i'm going to be working over here in
europe for a lot of this next year so
wow we'll be okay that's exciting i know
i always love that i think you get to
start dating again i think that's fun
you've become a grandfather again though
recently so congratulations
um do grandkids do they change your
relationships i'm just curious with your
kids because i see my mom
how she acted with me and then i see how
she acts with my kids
and then now we even have a different
relationship does that does that happen
to your family
yeah you know a bit i mean it's a little
different for me because
um the kids were back i guess you know
from the kovis so they were not out of
the house yet
and the thing about grandkids is you
always think in terms of well
they're long past when your kids are
already gone for for years
you know they're off for years doing
their own plans and now finally they're
going to have
children but this is my oldest son
cameron
and his lady vivian this is their
beautiful kids lua
who's three and and ryder who's just
three months
so it came on me a little fast you know
i didn't get that long as you said that
out your empty nest transition before
the grandchildren were there yeah so i'm
still working on that
uh quite honestly a little bit but i'm
looking forward to it they're they're
they're great kids
but i do get a kid a kick and it makes
me smile
watching my son and all the stuff that i
went through with him
you know and he was he was a tough
honorary tough honorary guy
uh as a kid and all of that and now
watching his it makes me just smile
and i just savor it in his misery when
he's having a tough day
you just do a karma walk by karma you do
the caramel walk by or then it's always
the beauty of the grandparent you saw
that's wonderful
here you go cam thanks very much bye
guys see you
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever